oui
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interio avec cette semaine
franck louvrier bonjour jours vous êtes
maire de la baule une immense plage de
l'atlantique à l'espère de la loi on va
en parler bien sûr mais avancer votre
connaissance de la vie politique
française que l'on va solliciter parce
que vous avez quand même été en charge
de la communication du président de la
république nicolas sarkozy mais avant
vous étiez aussi en charge du ministre
de l'intérieur et de bercy et de bercy
mais passé combien de temps 15 ans 15
ans matin midi et soir et bonne partie
de l'année ouais c'est supportable ça
vous êtes c'est des moments
extraordinaires c'est une vie sur le
moment c'est fatigant mais après avec le
recul on a une chance merveilleuse de
pouvoir vivre ces moments qui sont des
moments de tension des moments aussi
deux joueurs parce que ya pas que des
mauvaises nouvelles liées aussi des très
bonnes nouvelles avec une présidence de
la république a été agitée parce que le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy a été
aussi lui touché par une crise les
examine richert qui était sûr au niveau
économique presque plus grave que la
crise que l'on connaît avec une crise
qui venaient de l'extérieur et qu'il
fallait agir et à l'intérieur ouais on
va peut-être en parler parce que le coc
vidya pas il ya quelques ressemblances
parfois là dessus la situation politique
d'abord
d'aujourd'hui si on repasse le film de
ce qui se passe en france là ces
dernières semaines on retient évidemment
l'émergence d'une sorte d'ovni c'est à
dire eric zemmour sur le marché
politique et puis on retient la primaire
qui a lieu dans votre famille elle est
et d'où est sorti valérie pécresse c'est
quoi votre analyse de cette espèce de
tsunami
d'abord il ya toujours une
cristallisation qui se déroule à un
moment donné dans une campagne
électorale c'est vrai qu'on est à la
fois très proche c'est trois mois et
demi et puis à la fois très loin parce
que les choses ne se sont pas encore
stabilisées et si ce qui fait que un
ancien premier ministre expliquait que
la poutre travail maintenant elle
travaille beaucoup moins parce qu'on
voit bien les formations politiques
commencent à avoir leur candidat il n'en
reste plus quasiment qu'un à se déclarer
officiellement que le président la
république sortant donc les choses ont
commencé à se stabiliser
généralement en fin d'année parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire les
rendez vous familiaux de fin d'année il
y à des discussions politiques à la
veille d'une grande élection
présidentielle pendant le réveillon
exactement donc voilà donc on voit bien
et on l'a vu sur les dernières études
les choses commencent à se dissiper tout
ce qu'ils étaient je dirais troisième
homme ou parfois
aventuriers de la politique commence à
apparaître plus en marge et puis des
candidats importants commencent à
s'installer dans le paysage politique
oui mais alors quand vous parlez
d'aventuriers vous pensez à qui vous
pensez à eric zemmour par exemple non
droit il ya toutes sortes de candidats
où ça ira plus de 10 candidats à
l'élection présidentielle en france donc
c'est ça qui est assez toujours étonnant
mais le fait est c'est que c'est vrai
que aujourd'hui le troisième homme sait
où la troisième femme parfois c'est ça
paraît toujours 6 8 mois avant les
élections présidentielles on l'a vu avec
dominique de villepin on l'a vu avec
jean pierre chevènement et là c'est vrai
que eric zemmour était le troisième
homme et le fêtait c'est que maintenant
les choses commencent à s'organiser plus
entre deux poules ou trois peut-être
mais on voit bien que le la durée permet
de stabiliser les choses alors bon là
c'est le casting n'en parle du casting
mais il ya les tendances lourdes
derrière d'écriture du scénario il ya ce
glissement à droite de l'ensemble de
l'électorat ou du moins des ruines en
france elle est entre la droite et
l'extrême droite sapho faut pas ça on ne
peut pas éviter ce constat c'est un
constat qui est quasiment mathématiques
c'est que la france elle est entre la
droite et l'extrême droite donc c'est la
gauche qui a disparu la gauche parti oui
quand on voit comme générateur didata de
la bouche et même en dessous du seuil de
remboursement de sa campagne la 3 321 r
d et par les amis donc voilà donc on est
on est vraiment dans un contexte on voit
bien la situation politique va se passer
à droite et sur des thématiques de
droite oui mais est ce que est ce que
qu'est-ce que ça dit ça sur la société
française ça raconte cette jeune
histoire choses assez simple c'est que
il ya des thématiques qui doivent être
encore plus défendues par les
représentants politiques je pense à la
sécurité je pense à l'immigration je
pense à la fiscalité je pense aussi
maire à l'environnement parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire
l'environnement est plus un sujet de
droite qu'un sujet de gauche parce que
d'abord ça des conséquences économiques
et en plus c'est toujours les hommes les
femmes politiques de droite qui ont
énormément avancé sur ce sujet je veux
pas rentrer dans le détail mais que ce
soit le principe pollueur payeur que ce
soit le premier ministre de
l'environnement ça a été à droite tous
les le grenelle de l'environnement sous
nicolas sarkozy toutes les grandes
avancées en matière environnementale
elles sont venues de la droite donc tous
ces thématiques là vont apparaître
beaucoup plus distinctement à partir du
mois de janvier mais s'était déjà des
courants qui était qui étaient étaient
émergents autant de nicolas sarkozy
nicolas sarkozy avait fait une campagne
qui était quand même très à droite oui
après tout plus de demandes de droite
entre guillemets aujourd'hui en france
elle veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
gestions précédentes ont laissé tomber
un certain nombre de problèmes qui
touchent la formulation vous rappelle
quand même qu'il y avait un quinquennat
de gauche dont françois françois
hollande dont les manuels macron était
un homme important dans cette dispense
dispositif et c'est vrai que emmanuel
macron été élu avec la gauche et une
petite partie de la droite il a bien
senti que en fin de compte il fallait
gérer le pays à droite c'est un homme
intelligent et il a vu que son
positionnement n'était pas en fin de
compte coller à la réalité électorale et
notamment parlementaire c'est la raison
pour laquelle il est dans une situation
très compliquée aujourd'hui parce qu'à
la fois la poutre ne travaille plus si
je reprends l'expression d' edouard
philippe donc c'est à dire que la droite
se stabilise et la gauche l'a quitté ou
en tout cas les plus à même de pouvoir
peser dans la situation politique du
moment donc il va se trouver à ses seuls
aujourd'hui dans la position de candidat
à l'élection présidentielle comment
est-ce que vous qualifieriez la
politique qui a fait vingt emmanuel
macron
stratégique il a fait une politique de
droite mais quand on voit ce qu'il a
fait le quoi qu'il en coûte avec
évidemment beaucoup d'argent social
prévu quand on fait pas la réforme des
retraites c'est qu'on n'a pas fait une
politique de droite oui quand on n'est
pas capable d'assumer une réforme
qu'avait assumée notamment nicolas
sarkozy je pense qu'on n'est pas capable
de répondre à des enjeux qui sont des
enjeux majeurs sont des enjeux de demain
donc je pense pas qu'il a fait une
politique droite je pense qu'il avait
fait une politique en zigzag où il a
essayé à chaque fois d'obtenir je dirais
un quitus de d'un côté ou de l'autre de
l'échiquier politique et le fait est
c'est que quel homme est en forme en
même temps qu'elle est là réformes
marquantes du président sortant
le lancer est là pourquoi parce que il a
géré la crise mais nicolas sarkozy lui
aussi avait géré la crise vous l'avez
rappelé et il a quand même fait la
réforme sur les retraites donc vous
voyez bien il a été peut-être omnubilé
par la gestion de cette crise sanitaire
qui
je dirais n'a pas été parfaitement bien
gérer parce qu'on le voit encore dans
une situation à laquelle on met mais en
tout cas le fêtait c'est que aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas de réforme très marquante
de ce quinquennat alors est-ce qu'il ya
quand même pas de la part de votre
famille politique et de tous ceux qui
ont gouverné jusqu'à maintenant un mea
culpa affaire sur la politique
migratoire parce que c'est un sujet fort
dans la campagne électorale on le voit
bien c'est une préoccupation aussi un
certain nombre de parties de la
population notamment dans l'est dans les
villes c'est pas eu désir
il ya pas que la france qui a fait des
erreurs en la matière parce que toute
l'europe est concernée et je vous
rappelle pas les derniers événements qui
se sont déroulés en pologne donc non on
le voit bien on n'est peut-être pas
aller encore assez loin dans les
dispositifs à mettre en oeuvre je pense
notamment à la réforme des quotas qui
était indispensable on voit bien que le
parlement a un peu tremblé en la matière
et donc il ya sans doute des points sur
lequel il faut qu'on insiste de plus
dans les mois et les années à venir mais
vous savez quand on dit quand je me
scrute je m'inquiète quand je me compare
je me rassure quand je vois ce qui s'est
passé dans le quinquennat
monsieur hollande et même de celui de
mâcon par rapport à ce qui avait été
fait précédemment on est loin d'être
inquiet en la matière pour les
projections que pourrait faire
aujourd'hui un gouvernement de droite
mais ça veut dire par exemple que votre
candidate enfin la candidate de l air va
être obligé de durcir ses positions de
droite en obtiendra sa campagne interne
des républicains je n'ai pas le
sentiment qu'elle avait une position
faible si ce n'est pas elle était quand
même oui elle était assurée de dell elle
était considérée quand même d'avoir oui
alors bien sûr mais qui était dans ce
couloir de nage mais je vous rappelle
quand même que aujourd'hui elle fait
équipe avec eric ce type comme elle fait
équipe aussi à xavier bertrand est
affilié ou juin et mai michel barnier
c'est à dire que tout les à l'idée de
ces primaires internes qui en fin de
compte pas une primaire qui est une
élection sur une famille politique
c'était de créer à l'arrivée l'équipe de
france et l'équipe de france elle est là
mais la preuve c'est que les français
l'ont ressentie dans les dernières
études on le voit bien ils ont le
sentiment qui a eu un effet rassemblant
rassemblement autour de valérie pécresse
alors qu'on attend d'elle quoi enfin
quand on s'inquiète on ne pouvait penser
que ce serait le contraire que la
primaire aurait en fait détruit l'une
oui mais leur baisse et c'était un peu
son site ce qui s'était passé auparavant
où certaines élections internes ont été
des échecs je pense notamment copé
fillon et est même plus à même plus en
arrière balladur chirac avait laissé des
vraies cicatrices dans la famille
politique là aujourd'hui ce qui est une
réussite notamment la part de christian
jacob c'est d'avoir réussi à la fois
mais tous les candidats sur la même
ligne de départ et de d'avoir élu une
candidate qui le plus à même aujourd'hui
pouvoir rassembler et pouvoir gagner
l'élection présidentielle alors la
candidate ces petites faims c'est une
phase de l'événement le plus important
de ces derniers temps en matière de
sondage c'est que c'est la première fois
première fois dans l'histoire de france
qu'une femme selon les sondages peut
être élue présidente de la république
c'est sans doute une une révolution qui
et qui permet de dire que le plafond de
verre a peut-être enfin exploser c'est
vrai que la première femme candidate à
l'élection présidentielle c'est arlette
laguiller en 1974 bon peu de personnes
pensaient qu'ils pouvaient en rhizomes
de la république il
hélène raison du mariage je le sors très
peur du rejet de nicolas sarkozy à
l'époque mais ségolène royal n'a jamais
été potentiellement élus dans les
sondages alors que là pour la première
fois on a une candidate qui peut être
président république quant à la
crédibilité quand on a aussi
l'expérience parce que en étant
président d'une des plus grandes régions
de la plus grande région de france et
puis en étant et s'il a été ministre et
notre but du budget et aussi des
universités je vous rappelle que la
réforme a été compliqué elle a réussi à
la faire donc donc voilà donc on voit
bien à la fois à la la crédibilité elle
a la stature présidentielle et en plus
il ya une envie je pense en france de
vouloir avoir une femme présidente de la
république pas seulement en france
peut-être heures de route ou non mais on
regardait ya encore quelques jours on a
eu la nomination de la première ministre
de suède qui est une femme bien sûr et
puis bat l'angleterre à utah de chair
l'allemagne merkel enfin bref et la
france en fin de compte là dedans il
manque une petite touche de modernité
cette touche de modernité pour être là
oui mais enfin elle peut pas non plus
être élus ce n'est pas ce n'est pas un
argument lâcherai pas un argument dès
qu'on met sa crédibilité peut permettre
aussi d'amener à cette réflexion là
c'est à dire que sur sa crédibilité
personne ne conteste elle a vraiment
aujourd'hui installé une position qui
une position de leader on se retrouve
dans un quart de seconde 1 on fait une
petite pause à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
voilà retour sur le plateau de la grande
interview avec franck louvrier qui est
le maire de la baule le vice-président
aussi de la région pays-de-loire
wah pays de la loire oui lr cinq décès
de votre famille qui a une candidate à
la présidentielle dont les sondages
disent qu'il est assez bien placé est ce
que le l'ancien président de la ligue
avec lequel vous avez travaillé pendant
quoi vingt ans presque
va se prononcer vous savez il est très
attaché à sa famille politique
maintenant est ce qu il veut rentrer
dans la politique politicienne ou dans
la campagne électorale j'ai pas ce
sentiment là ci s'est retirée c'est
justement pour paris participé vous
savez toute l'affection et l'amitié
qu'il a pour valérie pécresse il a même
décoré de la légion d'honneur et
quelques temps donc non c'est je pense
que il faut respecter ce recul qui là
qu'il a souhaité depuis quelques temps
maintenant et voilà c'est ça fait partie
de ces hommes qui ont marqué notre pays
qui pourrait à un moment ou un autre
avoir un rôle à jouer et on n'en sait
rien on sait pas quelle émotion du pays
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui il est
resté en retrait faut respecter ce
retrait alors on l'a dit un dans la
première partie cet entretien c'est une
femme mais c'est pas forcément c'est
évidemment un atout dans la conjoncture
actuelle mais c'est pas forcément un
atout qu'elle utilisera c'est pas une
carte l epad militante féministe mais le
maïs mais c'est aussi une femme qui a un
peu d'expérience en gouvernant beaucoup
vraiment et
enfin à ella ella elle va avoir un
certain nombre de dossiers qui vont être
des dossiers compliqués à résoudre et
notamment le redressement économique
oui même si aujourd'hui on voit la
situation économique avec la moue vers 6
7% de croissance annoncées par la banque
de france donc on le voit bien il ya une
dynamique une dynamique qui n'est pas dû
à la politique gouvernementale qui est
due aussi à un mouvement européen et je
dirais même international mais c'est
dynamique là il va falloir la prendre en
compte dans notre politique
de croissance et ça ça va être un enjeu
majeur alors premier point comment vous
vous juger la façon dont dans dans le
président macron à gérer la crise qu
vide et la crise économique il ya eu des
mesures incontestablement qu'on était
indispensable et qui ont été prises pas
uniquement par l'état aussi par les
collectivités locales parce que parfois
on oublie que les régions notamment et
puis aussi les intercommunalités ont eu
un rôle très important en matière de
soutien à l'ensemble du tissu économique
ça a été le cas pour la région des pays
de la loire avec christelle morançais on
a pris des mesures qui étaient des
mesures à la fois je dirais locale et
régionale c'est-à-dire pour permettre de
pouvoir aider l'ensemble des entreprises
et pour éviter maintenant parce que ça
aussi la deuxième étape qui se retrouve
face à des murs de dettes trop trop
important et donc il ya tout un
accompagnement aujourd'hui avec des
mesures qui leur permettent de passer la
vague en espérant que tout ça est
derrière nous mais commence mais ça a
été financée par des fonds nationaux a
beaucoup d'abord à des garanties par
l'état cc c'est clair que c'est toujours
de l'argent des contribuables donc ça
c'est clair mais il fallait mettre le
paquet à un moment donné et ça à la fois
l'état les collectivités l'ont fait
parfaitement bien puisqu'on a vu quand
même un moment même de la crise de
coville sait que c'est que les maires
ont dû prendre en main un certain nombre
de problèmes quotidiens midi n'était pas
pris par l'état elles ont même des
compétences qu'on avait pas moi j'ai pas
la compétence en est à la bourre on a
été vaillant femme vous fait tomber la
colère par rapport au pouvoir central et
je suis tout nouveau casque au niveau
des bâtis et les charges sont en colère
parce que femme et non mais on a mis en
place comme un centre de vaccination
qu'on a ouvert de février à septembre on
n'est toujours pas remboursé c'est plus
de 600000 euros de l'argent des
contribuables beaunois qui n'a pas été
remboursé par l'état alors qu'on nous
avait dit que bien évidemment serait
remboursé immédiatement on est obligé
d'en rouvrir un deuxième parce que bien
sûr à la fois les agences régionales de
santé c'est à dire l'état voit que les
maires sont indispensables dans le
dispositif de vaccination qu'il faut
mettre en place dans toute la france
donc donc il ya eu peut-être de la part
du gouvernement et passant du président
de république cette remarque qui se dit
en gros ben la france c'est pas que
paris c'est aussi les collectivités
c'est aussi l'engagement de tous ses
élus ce qu'on a reproché à l'équipe
gouvernementale au premier ministre misa
santé mais aussi au président de la
république c'est de ne pas toujours dire
la vérité pour moi c'est toujours un peu
en retard d'être en retard d'un regard
et prospectif mais la question je
voulais vous poser parce que vous vous
avez vécu la crise de 2009 crise
financière au cours de laquelle
franchement le président d'airbus n'a
pas toujours dit la vérité de la gravité
de la crise qui celui qui fit ce présent
oui mais je vous laisse il a le droit de
mentir est ce qu'un président d'un an
non on a on n'a pas le droit de mentir
on ne leur donne pas tout dire c'est pas
là c'est pas la même chose certes il ya
des moments où vous pouvez dire des
choses puis à d'autres moments on
pouvais pas le dire parce que justement
c'est propice ou pas dans la villa mais
c'est à maquereau le droit de ne pas
avoir tout dit par contre je reproche
par exemple si vous prenez la
comparaison avec 2008 la première action
fait nicolas sarkozy lorsqu'il voit la
crise il met les banquiers tous autour
de la table les accédants à réviser leur
avait la pression
combien de temps on a attendu pour que
emmanuel macron prennent les affaires en
main et mettre la pression à la fois sur
les laboratoires à la fois sur tout le
monde médical ça a mis beaucoup plus de
temps donc qui a manqué beaucoup de
réactivité et puis manqué beaucoup de
prospective c'est à dire on a bien vu le
drame sur les masques on a bien vu
l'ensemble des déclarations
ministérielles qui était complètement je
dirais en adéquation par rapport à ce
que disait même les homologues européens
et donc là on s'est retrouvé dans une
mauvaise gestion de la crise oui mais je
vous pose cette question parce que
j'étais témoin de cette réunion à
l'elysée au cours de laquelle
sarkozy était était président du g7 de
l'europe tout le monde était là on
risquait le bank run c'est à dire la
faillite générale des banques mondiales
à l'époque ce jour là le président
macron ne le président sarkozy n'a pas
elle n'a pas dit un peu plus non mais
nous étions dans une situation grave ici
au bord du gouffre si vous dites ça vous
imaginez l'effet de halo ça peut avoir
sur la consommation sur le comportement
des français sur les tensions sociales
etc il faut faire attention parce que
notre pays est très centralisateur et
tout ce qui part de l'elysée un effet
beaucoup plus fort que bien évidemment
dans un pays comme le nôtre qu'un pays
de un peu plus de 60 millions
d'habitants vous imaginez bien que
les conséquences sont graves en termes
de défait de déclarations du président
la république donc chaque chose doit
être mesuré c'est un peu mon métier mais
là dans la crise ducobu n'y avait pas
d'autres solutions que celles qui ont
été prises dans la crise du coup vite je
pense que il y aurait pu être beaucoup
plus en amont des décisions c'est-à-dire
ne pas attendre que les choses se
présentent à lui même et que d'autres
pays européens prennent des initiatives
avant lui je pense que la france pouvait
encore leader en la matière ça a
provoqué un certain nombre de mutations
on a assisté quand même à une résilience
formidable des entreprises françaises se
sont adaptés est-ce que ça va être
durable cette mutation là est ce que ça
change beaucoup le quotidien des
entreprises est ce que vous le sentez
dans une région qui est très dynamique
et nous on est la première région en
matière économique parce que en fin de
compte on a le plus faible taux de
chômage en france mais mais au-delà de
ça je pense que c'est surtout on a le
sentiment qu'il ya des nouveaux
comportements en fin de compte qui aura
eu bien sûr dans le monde de
l'entreprise un avant et un après qu
vide et je le dis très clairement pour
des comportements de consommateurs comme
des entreprises le distant ciel là des
urbanisations très clair on le voit bien
mois genre à la baule on sent vite
compte c'est à dire que il ya plus en
plus de gens qui veulent vivre et
travailler au pays des vacances comme on
dit mais qui s'installe mais c'est tout
l'effet ouest 1 il y avait là des
ménagements ils rentrent vers l'arabe un
hebdomadaire connu que pour ne pas le
citer le point a fait la une nature les
gens partent de nantes et c'est le
succès de la baule pourquoi ce parce que
c'est à à 5 à 70 km de distance et que
les gens veulent autant la qualité de
vie que la vivre à 20 et ils savent très
bien qu'ils peuvent travailler à
distance qui peuvent rejoindre la
capitale en trois heures donc tout ça
fait que il ya un choix et qui est un
phénomène qui est un vrai effet côte
ouest de saint malo à biarritz c'est à
dire que la décentralisation fin de
deauville a bien arriver si vous voulez
on peut même monter mais le hors bord
voire 10 mai mais il ya un phénomène de
décentralisation qui est pas due
justement à l'état
c'est pas des mesures de
décentralisation mais dus au
comportement des gens c'est d
urbanisation en fin de compte les gens
quittent les grandes villes pour se dire
que moi je préfère scolariser mes
enfants au bord de la mer je préfère
avoir une qualité de vie exceptionnelle
parfois peut-être renier un peu sur des
activités que j'aurais pu trouver dans
des villes plus importantes mais surtout
que maintenant avec les le phénomène du
numérique vous pouvez bien sûr avoir le
dernier factor vous pouvez avoir la
dernière pièce de théâtre zahoud maires
maires de villes comme ça qui récupère
et des citadins vous êtes équipé pour
satisfaire d'avoir une chance formidable
c'est que je passe de 17000 habitants à
180 milles était donc c'est une bonne
chose il a vibré sur 187 donc voilà donc
je vais service je suis capable
d'absorber des dizaines de milliers
d'habitants à les écoles rapidement
alors les écoles vont fermer les écoles
il faut du temps mais un même passé de
17000 à 25000 pour moi ce serait très
bien parce que ça me permet d'avoir une
économie à l'année parce qu'en fin de
compte nous de plus en plus c'est n'est
plus une station balnéaire la baule
c'est une ville banner c'est une ville
admet donc on obligé aussi la porte et
les offres culturelles parce que les
gens veulent avoir une vie quotidienne
anglais au delà de la qualité de vie
donc c'est important pis on doit aussi
s'adapter on a un nouveau centre court
king qui vient d'ouvrir au dessus de la
gare enfin on essaye de s'adapter à
l'évolution de la consommation et
notamment de l'évolution des entreprises
sur le marché français vous êtes en
compétition avec deauville vous êtes en
matière de tourisme d'affaires en appel
le maïs oui tout à fait important et est
de plus en plus en concurrence c'est à
dire en quelques heures quand vous
prenez la ligne tgv pour parler de paris
à la baule vous avez un palais des
congrès à angers vous avez palais des
congrès au mans vous avez un palais des
congrès vous n'avez pas les gants à la
roche-sur-yon d'un appareil de rouvray à
la baule vous avez même un centre au puy
du fou enfin bref donc tout ça fait que
on a on a dans dans une région qui fait
cinq départements énormément de
concurrence et donc il faut des offres
nouvelles et c'est ça tout l'enjeu
aujourd'hui du tourisme d'affaires c'est
d'apporter des offres nouvelles pour
permettre aux entreprises de revenir en
espérant que le coc vite soit derrière
nous de revenir au présentiel et un peu
moins à distance est ce que vous disent
les gens qui veulent aller qui
choisissent cannes ou qui choisissent
devises il n'en avait pas d'eau billy
pleut toujours et à cannes il fait trop
chaud non mais chacun a sa particularité
je pense que l' avantage de la baule
c'est que c'est vraiment un trois heures
de tgv 3h15 de tgv de paris mais c'est
important mais vous savez ça avantage
car il a lu à 2 à 1h30 d'avion avions
une heure et demie d'avion il faut y
aller aux toilettes repasser mais l'élan
est là les normands et mais on a une
bonne distance en fin de compte parce
que ça permet aussi de faire des nuitées
ce que vous savez qu'en matière
touristique on mesure en 8es et donc
plus on a nui tu es mieux celle alors et
puis c'est vrai que on a une offre très
diverses et ça c'est assez formidable
parce que vous avez à la fois du
patrimoine vous avez à la fois la
possibilité de vivre à l'année tout en
étant je dirais dans un contexte assez
exceptionnel donc de vacances donc cessé
d atouts qui sont formidables pour
l'ensemble les habitants vous le vendez
vient en plus en avoir six équipes etc
comment se passent les réservations pour
noël on est plutôt optimiste pour la
simple et bonne raison que quand même
mais c'est vrai il ya eu un phénomène
vacances bleu-blanc-rouge déjà cet été
et là malheureusement avec le retour de
l'inquiétude à l'endroit du coc vide on
s'aperçoit que les gens reviennent
réservés en france plus tôt et à
proximité plutôt que de partir à
l'étranger comme vous savez des
destinations comme le maroc sont
quasiment totalement fermée et c'était
quand même un élément attractif en fin
d'année et donc beurre en plus de
touristes se dit tiens on va on va
profiter de l'air marin alors vous vous
m'avez dit tout à l'heure avant de
commencer vous organisiez à un noël
russe oui la baule oui en inde on a on a
une exposition sur le noël russe parce
que je voulais aussi montrer que la
russie s'est pas uniquement le sujet
politique il ya aussi des ans des sujets
politiques et les rapports politiques
sur mac c'est aussi une richesse
culturelle et et malheureusement on
parle pas souvent la richesse culturelle
et la fondation vuitton a oui mais pas
assez donc une ville comme la nôtre on
zone d'exposition dans une vous avez une
chapelle une collection privée dans une
chapelle désacralisée est au centre de
la ville oui vous savez que la candidate
à l air connaît bien la russie ouais
c'est bien la russie oui oui tout à fait
je crois même qu'elles pratiquent un peu
la langue oui donc oui dont elle est là
elle pratique même plusieurs langues est
là cette ouverture vers de nombreux pays
européens c'est un manque ça c'est un
déficit dans toutes les les gouvernants
ce soit nicolas sarkozy françois
hollande emmanuel macron on a manqué un
certain nombre de rendez vous avec la
russie oui et notamment pas que des
rendez vous politiques parce que à
chaque fois on est toujours à l'aune de
rapport politique il ya la culture il ya
là géographique et passionnant jeudi la
ville et y l'économie on a vraiment des
thèmes sur lequel on refuse de l'aborder
tout ça parce que parfois les rapports
politiques sont compliquées fente
ouvriers merci beaucoup mais que vous
êtes maire de la baule très grande
station balnéaire une très grande plage
1 9 km au sud de la bretagne vous êtes
breton oui bien sûr un breton et on
al'avantage et au sud de la bretagne
donc sous le soleil maire de la baule
vice président de la région des pays de
loire merci mille fois franck louvrier
on retrouve les missions rediffusion
voilà on retrouve aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux en replay on la retrouve sur le
site internet rt france point tv merci à
tous à très bientôt
[Musique]